on this episode we talk to da ki about
how they're using Google cloud for their
applications chat BOTS and machine
learning so can you tell me a little bit
more about what you actually use inside
of Google cloud - like for instance the
machine learning and any other products
that you might use definitely so a lot
of what we build on the cloud is mostly
on the Google cloud so we use many
different services that Google Offers we
try to be as cloud native as we can but
there are some important aspects of
Google cloud that makes our job easier
and gets to market sooner so largely our
ecosystem of tools that we use on Google
cloud so we use gke the kubernetes
engine it's a fantastic product from
Google in my opinion we build a lot of
micro services that are based on docker
and then we are able to rule her out on
GK as multiple nodes and paths and it
brings in auto scaling aspects for us
which is fantastic so a lot of our data
collection micro services are basically
collecting data across different apps
and users but also from our partners so
one line of business that da kia has is
where we license these technologies to
our partners and they have millions of
users from which we are able to collect
that data that's coming in so all the
data that's collected by these different
micro services which has burstable
capacity are actually stored on GCS the
Google Cloud Storage so it's it's
important for us to understand that
cloud storage provides the reliability
that we need because then we can use
multiple clouds if we need because it
becomes a single point of entry for us
to like share it across different clouds
we also use many of the databases that
we have used obviously cloud sequel
proxy which makes the job of like being
able to connect the different services
really incredibly simple for us the
other thing that we have done well on
Google cloud is be able to like build
parallelization so that we can train
many many jobs concurrently or
simultaneously so to speak so we can
experiment with different hyper
parameters we use bigquery for a lot of
our data analytics downstream so based
on how sort of users are collecting
information especially on events and
other aspects we can sort of throw that
big query and see what are some
interesting correlations that we can see
there most of our machine learning
models are built today using tensor flow
we found that to be production ready
from get-go which is something we are
very happy about and I think it's also
easy to hire today relatively in the
world of AI and deep learning many of
them are actually being trained on
tensor flow which is a good thing with
the help of what Google is doing across
the ecosystem we also use some of the
other specific hyper specialized AI
modules you have for example Google
vision API is something we use for
extracting certain information out of
medical in the medical context
specifically around like pill bottles
and bonding boxes and things like that
so you also mentioned you and I'll pee a
little while ago and then earlier you
talked about the chat BOTS how our users
using chat BOTS and what does dog AI
doing with us it's a great question so
one thing I did not mention is that
dokie I also has several chat BOTS so we
have a direct-to-consumer chat part
which is for mental health so we have
more than 600,000 users on the platform
it's a chat bot that runs off of
facebook messenger what we have seen
with chat BOTS is a very interesting
phenomena because for certain types of
diseases patients prefer talking to a
bot as opposed to a medical professional
because one medical professional are not
necessarily available in their area
where they have these issues and BOTS
have no judgement so they are they are
not being watched or being judged by
someone so we have mental health chat
BOTS but we also work with a lot of our
partners to sort of roll out very
vertical specific chat BOTS for example
for insurance companies where we can do
member engagement we are also building
chat BOTS bar for very specific disease
verticals in the future but what they do
is that they are somewhat generalized
enough that now we could take a model
like that and bring our own data and
through our specific data and
an improved version of that that's
somewhat hyper focused in the domain
that we have of course we need a lot of
data for it to improve but then these
models then become really valuable where
you could engage them for example in
chat BOTS where you could predict the
next set of sequence of things that our
user may ask so you can give them better
services right away or there is enough
contextual memory of the previous
conversation so you know how to engage
the user further thanks so much for
coming in Akshay and telling us about
how doc AI is working with the cloud
Thank You Marc this was really exciting
I'm very happy to be here and hoping to
see many more talks in the world of
healthcare that's important for the
general echo system that Google is doing
a great job absolutely thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this
conversation with da ki check out the
stack chat playlist for more great
videos
[Music]
you